The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's
say that I tell you
that I'm interested in a gas
that has some temperature.
I specify, let's
say, temperature.
Pressure is room
temperature, room pressure.
And I tell you how
many particles I have.
So that's [INAUDIBLE] for
you what the macro state is.
And I want to then see what the
corresponding micro state is.
So I take one of these
boxes, whereas this is a box
that I draw in three dimensions,
I can make a correspondence
and draw this is 6N-dimensional
coordinate space, which
would be hard for me to draw.
But basically, a space
of six n dimensions.
I figure out where the
position, and the particles,
and the momenta are.
And I sort of find that there
is a corresponding micro state
that corresponds to
this macro state.
OK, that's fine.
I made the correspondence.
But the thing is that I can
imagine lots and lots of boxes
that have exactly the same
macroscopic properties.
That is, I can imagine
putting here side by side
a huge number of these boxes.
All of them are described
by exactly the same volume,
pressure, temperature,
for example.
The same macro state.
But for each one of them, when
I go and find the macro state,
I find that it is
something else.
So I will be having
different micro states.
So this correspondence
is certainly
something where
there should be many,
many points here that correspond
to the same thermodynamic
representation.
So faced with that,
maybe it makes sense
to follow Gibbs and
define an ensemble.
So what we say is,
we are interested
in some particular macro state.
We know that they correspond
to many, many, many
different potential
micro states.
Let's try to make a map of
as many micro states that
correspond to the
same macro state.
So consider n copies of
the same macro state.
And this would correspond
to n different points
that I put in this
6N-dimensional phase space.
And what I can do is I can
define an ensemble density.
I go to a particular
point in this space.
So let's say I pick some
point that corresponds
to some set of p's and q's here.
And what I do is
I draw a box that
is 6N-dimensional
around this point.
And I define a density
in the vicinity
of that point, as follows.
Actually, yeah.
What I will do is I will
count how many of these points
that correspond to micro
states fall within this box.
So at the end is the number
of mu points in this box.
And what I do is I divide
by the total number.
I expect that the result
will be proportional
to the volume of the box.
So if I make the box
bigger, I will have more.
So I divide by the
volume of the box.
So this is, let's call d
gamma is the volume of box.
Of course, I have
to do this in order
to get a nice result by
taking the limit where
the number of members of the
ensemble becomes quite large.
And then presumably, this will
give me a well-behaved density.
In this limit, I guess I want
to also have the size of the box
go to 0.
OK?
Now, clearly, with
the definitions
that I have made, if
I were to integrate
this quantity against the
volume d gamma, what I would get
is the integral dN over N.
N is, of course, a constant.
And the integral of dN
is the total number.
So this is 1.
So we find that this quantity
rho that I have constructed
satisfies two properties.
Certainly, it is
positive, because I'm
counting the number of points.
Secondly, it's normalized to 1.
So this is a nice
probability density.
So this ensemble density is a
probability density function
in this phase space
that I have defined.
OK?
All right.
So once I have a
probability, then I
can calculate various
things according
to the rules of probability
that we defined before.
So for example, I can
define an ensemble average.
Maybe I'm interested
in the kinetic energy
of the particles of the gas.
So there is a function
O that depends
on the sum of all
of the p squareds.
In general, I have some function
of O that depends on p and q.
And what I defined the ensemble
average would be the average
that I would calculate
with this probability.
Because I go over all of
the points in phase space.
And let me again emphasize
that what I call d gamma
then really is the
product over all points.
For each point, I have to
make a volume in both momentum
and in coordinate.
It's a 6N-dimensional
volume element.
I have to multiply
the probability, which
is a function of p and
q against this O, which
is another function of p and q.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the
division by M necessary
to make it into a
probability density?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Otherwise, you
would still have a density.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
When I would integrate then,
I would get the total number.
But the total
number is up to me,
how many members of
the ensemble I took,
it's not a very
well-defined quantity.
It's an arbitrary quantity.
If I set it to become very
large and divide by it,
then I will get something
that is nicely a probability.
And we've developed
all of these tools
for dealing with probabilities.
So that would go to waste
if I don't divide by.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Question.
When you say that
you have set numbers,
do you assume that you have
any more informations than just
the microscopic
variables GP and--
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: So how can we put a
micro state in correspondence
with a macro state if
there is-- on the-- like,
with a few variables?
And do you need
to-- from-- there's
like five variables,
defined down
to 22 variables for
all the particles?
PROFESSOR: So that's
what I was saying.
It is not a one-to-one
correspondence.
That is, once I specify
temperature, pressure,
and the number of particles.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: My question is, if
you generate identical macro
states, and create--
which macro states--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Depending on
some kind of a rule on how
you make this
correspondence, you
can get different
ensemble densities, right?
PROFESSOR: No.
That is, if I, in principle
and theoretically,
go over the entirety of all
possible macroscopic boxes
that have these
properties, I will
be putting infinite
number of points in this.
And I will get some
kind of a density.
AUDIENCE: What if you, say,
generate infinite number
of points, but all in
the case when, like,
all molecules of gas are
in right half of the box?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Is that a thermodynamically
equilibrium state?
AUDIENCE: Did you
mention it needed to be?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I said that-- I'm
talking about things
that can be described
macroscopically.
Now, the thing
that you mentioned
is actually something that
I would like to work with,
because ultimately,
my goal is not only
to describe equilibrium, but
how to reach equilibrium.
That is, I would like precisely
to answer the question, what
happens if you start in a
situation where all of the gas
is initially in one
half of the room?
And as long as there
is a partition,
that's a well-defined
macroscopic state.
And then I remove the partition.
And suddenly, it is a
non-equilibrium state.
And presumably, over time,
this gas will occupy that.
So there is a physical process
that we know happens in nature.
And what I would
like eventually to do
is to also describe
that physical process.
So what I will do
is I will start
with the initial
configuration with everybody
in the half space.
And I will calculate
the ensemble
that corresponds to that.
And that's unique.
Then I remove the partition.
Then each member of the ensemble
will follow some trajectory
as it occupies eventually
the entire box.
And we would like to follow
how that evolution takes place
and hopefully show that
you will always have,
eventually, at the end of
the day, the gas occupying
the system uniform.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
but just would it
be more correct to generate
many, many different micro
states as the macro states
which correspond to them?
And how many different--
PROFESSOR: What rule do
you use for generating
many, many micro states?
AUDIENCE: Like, all uniformly
arbitrary perturbations
of particles always to
put them in phase space.
And look to-- like, how
many different micro states
give rise to the
same macro state?
PROFESSOR: Oh, but you
are already then talking
about the macro state?
AUDIENCE: A portion--
which description
do you use as the first one
to generate the second one?
So in your point of view,
let's do-- [INAUDIBLE]
to macro states, and
go to micro state.
But can you reverse?
PROFESSOR: OK.
I know that the way that
I'm presenting things
will lead ultimately to a useful
description of this procedure.
You are welcome
to try to come up
with a different prescription.
But the thing that I want
to ensure that you agree
is that the procedure
that I'm describing here
has no logical inconsistencies.
I want to convince you of that.
I am not saying that this
is necessarily the only one.
As far as I know,
this is the only one
that people have worked with.
But maybe somebody can come up
with a different prescription.
So maybe there is another one.
Maybe you can work on it.
But I want you
to, at this point,
be convinced that this is
a well-defined procedure.
OK?
AUDIENCE: But because it's
a well-defined procedure,
if you did exist
on another planet
or in some universe where
the physics were different,
the point is, you can use this.
But can't you use this
for information in general
when you want to-- like, if
you have-- the only requirement
is that at a fine
scale, you have
a consistent way of describing
things; and at a large scale,
you have a way of making
sense of generalizing.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So it's sort
of like a compression
of data, or I use [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Except that part of this was
starting with some physics
that we know.
So indeed, if you were
in a different universe--
and later on in the course, we
will be in a different universe
where the rules are
not classical or
quantum-mechanical.
And you have to throw
away this description
of what a micro state is.
And you can still go through
the entire procedure.
But I want to do is to
follow these set of equations
of motion and this
description of micro state,
and see where it leads us.
And for the gas in this room, it
is a perfectly good description
of what's happened.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Maybe a
simpler question.
Is big rho defined
only in spaces
where there are micro states?
Like, is there anywhere where
there isn't a micro state?
PROFESSOR: Yes, of course.
So if I have--
thinking about a box,
and if I ask what
is rho out here,
I would say the
answer is rho is 0.
But if you like, you can
say rho is defined only
within this space of the box.
So the description
of the macro state
which has something
to do with the box,
over which I am
considering, will also
limit what I can describe.
Yes.
And certainly, as far as if I
were to change p with velocity,
let's say, then you
would say, a space
where V is greater than speed
of light is not possible.
That's the point.
So your rules of physics
will also define implicitly
the domain over
which this is there.
But that's all
part of mechanics.
So I'm going to assume that
the mechanics part of it
is you are comfortable.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In your definition
of the ensemble average,
are you integrating over all
6N dimensions of phase space?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So why would your
average depend on p and q?
If you integrate?
PROFESSOR: The average is
of a function of p and q.
So in the same sense
that, let's say,
I have a particle of
gas that is moving on,
and I can write the
symbol, p squared over 2m,
what is this average?
The answer will be KT
over 2, for example.
It will not depend on p.
But the quantity that I'm
averaging inside the triangle
is a function of p and q.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if it's an
integration, or basically
the--?
PROFESSOR: The physical
limit of the problem.
AUDIENCE: Given a macro state?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So typically, we
will be integrating q
over the volume of a box,
and p from minus infinity
to infinity,
because classically,
without relativity,
this is a lot.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So why is the [INAUDIBLE] from
one end for every particle,
instead of just
scattering space,
would you have a [INAUDIBLE]?
Or is that the same thing?
PROFESSOR: I am not sure
I understand the question.
So if I want to, let's say,
find out just one particle that
is somewhere in this box, so
there is a probability that it
is here, there is a
probability that it is there,
there is a probability
that it is there.
The integral of that probability
over the volume of the room
is one.
So how do I do that?
I have to do an integral
over dx, dy, dz, probability
as a function of x, y, and z.
Now I just repeat that 6N times.
OK?
All right.
So that's the description.
But the first question
to sort of consider
is, what is equilibrium
in this perspective?
Now, we can even be
generous, although it's
a very questionable thing,
to say that, really,
when I sort of talk about the
kinetic energy of the gas,
maybe I can replace that
by this ensemble average.
Now, if I'm in
equilibrium, the results
should not depend as
a function of time.
So I expect that if
I'm calculating things
in equilibrium, the result
of equations such as this
should not depend on time,
which is actually a problem.
Because we know that if I take
a picture of all of these things
that I am constructing
my ensemble with
and this picture is at
time t, at time t plus dt,
all of the particles
have moved around.
And so the point that was
here, the next instant of time
is going to be somewhere else.
This is going to
be somewhere else.
Each one of these is flowing
around as a function of time.
OK?
So the picture that I
would like you to imagine
is you have a box, and there's
a huge number of bees or flies
or whatever your
preferred insect
is, are just moving around.
OK?
Now, you can sort of then
take pictures of this cluster.
And it's changing potentially
as a function of time.
And therefore, this
density should potentially
change as a function of time.
And then this answer could
potentially depend on time.
So let's figure out how
is this density changing
as a function of time.
And hope that ultimately,
we can construct a solution
for the equation that
governs the change in density
as a function of time that
is in fact invariant in time.
It is going back to my
flies or bees or whatever,
you can imagine a
circumstance in which
the bees are constantly
moving around.
Each individual bee is now
here, then somewhere else.
But all of your pictures have
the same density of bees,
because for every bee
that left the box,
there was another bee
that came in its place.
So one can imagine
a kind of situation
where all of these
points are moving around,
yet the density
is left invariant.
And in order to find whether
such a density is possible,
we have to first know
what is the equation that
governs the evolution
of that density.
And that is given by the
Liouville's equation.
So this governs evolution
of rho with time.
OK.
So let's kind of blow off the
picture that we had over there.
Previously, they're all
of these coordinates.
There is some point
in coordinate space
that I am looking at.
Let's say that the point
that I am looking at is here.
And I have constructed
a box around it
like this in the
6N-dimensional space.
But just to be precise, I will
be looking at some particular
coordinate q alpha and the
conjugate momentum p alpha.
So this is my original
point corresponds to, say,
some specific version
of q alpha p alpha.
And that I have, in
this pair of dimensions,
created a box that
in this direction
has size dq alpha, in this
direction has size dp alpha.
OK?
And this is the picture
that I have at some time t.
OK?
Then I look at an instant of
time that is slightly later.
So I go to a time
that is t plus dt.
I find that the point that
I had initially over here
as the center of this
box has moved around
to some other
location that I will
call q alpha prime,
p alpha prime.
If you ask me what is q alpha
prime and p alpha prime,
I say, OK, I know
that, because I
know with equations of motion.
If I was running
this on a computer,
I would say that q alpha prime
is q alpha plus the velocity
q alpha dot dt, plus
order of dt squared,
which hopefully, I will choose
a sufficient and small time
interval I can ignore.
And similarly, p
alpha prime would
be p alpha plus p alpha
dot dt order of dt squared.
OK?
So any point that was in
this box will also move.
And presumably,
close-by points will
be moving to close-by points.
And overall, anything
that was originally
in this square actually
projected from a larger
dimensional cube will be part
of a slightly distorted entity
here.
So everything that was
here is now somewhere here.
OK?
I can ask, well, how wide is
this new distance that I have?
So originally, the two
endpoints of the square
were a distance dq alpha apart.
Now they're going to be a
distance dq alpha prime apart.
What is dq alpha prime?
I claim that dq alpha prime
is whatever I had originally,
but then the two N's
are moving at slightly
different velocities,
because the velocity depends
on where you are in phase space.
And so the difference in
velocity between these two
points is really the derivative
of the velocity with respect
to the separation that I have
between those two points, which
is dq times dq alpha.
And this is how
much I would have
expanded plus higher order.
And I can apply the same thing
in the momentum direction.
The new vertical
separation dp alpha prime
is different from what
it was originally,
because the two
endpoints got stretched.
The reason they
got stretched was
because their velocities
were different.
And their difference
is just the derivative
of velocity with
respect to separation
times their small separation.
And if I make
everything small, I
can, in principle, write
higher order terms.
But I don't have to
worry about that.
OK?
So I can ask, what is the area
of this slightly distorted
square?
As long as the dt is
sufficiently small,
all of the distortions, et
cetera, will be small enough.
And you can convince
yourself of this.
And what you will find
is that the product
of dq alpha prime,
dp alpha prime,
if I were to multiply
these things,
you can see that dq
alpha and dp alpha
is common to the two of them.
So I have dq alpha, dp alpha.
From multiplying these
two terms, I will get one.
And then I will get two
terms that are order of dt,
that I will get from dq alpha
dot with respect to dq alpha,
plus dp alpha dot with
respect to dp alpha.
And then there will be terms
that are order of dt squared
and higher order
types of things.
OK?
So the distortion in the
area of this particle,
or cross section, is
governed by something
that is proportional to dt.
And dq alpha dot over dq alpha
plus dp alpha dot dp alpha.
But I have formally here for
what P i dot and qi dot are.
So this is the dot notation
for the time derivative
other than the one that
I was using before.
So q alpha dot, what
do I have for it?
It is dh by dp alpha.
So this is d by dq alpha
of the H by dp alpha.
Whereas p alpha dot, from which
I have to evaluate d by dp
alpha, p alpha dot is
minus dH by dq alpha.
So what do I have?
I have two second derivatives
that appear with opposite sign
and hence cancel each other out.
OK?
So essentially, what we find
is that the volume element
is preserved under this process.
And I can apply this to
all of my directions.
And hence, conclude that
the initial volume that
was surrounding my point
is going to be preserved.
OK?
So what that means is that these
classical equations of motion,
the Hamiltonian equations, for
this description of micro state
that involves the
coordinates and momenta
have this nice property
that they preserve volume
of phase space as
they move around.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If the Hamiltonian has
expontential time dependence,
that doesn't work anymore.
PROFESSOR: No.
So that's why I did not
put that over there.
Yes.
And actually, this is
sometimes referred to
as being something like
an incompressible fluid.
Because if you kind of deliver
hydrodynamics for something
like water if you regard
it as incompressible,
the velocity field
has the condition
that the divergence
of the velocity is 0.
Here, we are looking at a
6N-dimensional mention velocity
field that is composed of q
alpha dot and p alpha dot.
And this being 0 is
really the same thing
as the divergence in this
6N-dimensional space is 0.
And that's a property of
the Hamiltonian dynamics
that one has.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could
you briefly go over
why you have to divide
by the separation
when you expand the times
between the displacement?
PROFESSOR: Why do I have to
multiply by the separation?
AUDIENCE: Divide by.
PROFESSOR: Where do I divide?
AUDIENCE: dq alpha by--
PROFESSOR: Oh, this.
Why do I have to
take a derivative.
So I have two points here.
All of my points
are moving in time.
So if these things were
moving with uniform velocity,
one second later, this
would have moved here,
this would have moved
the same distance,
so that the separation
between them
would have been
maintained if they
were moving with
the same velocity.
So if you are following
somebody and you
are moving with the
same velocity as them,
thus, your separation
does not change.
But if one of you is going
faster than the other one,
then the difference
in velocity will
determine how you separate.
And what is the
difference in velocity?
The difference in velocity
depends, in this case,
to how far apart the points are.
So the difference between
velocity here and velocity
here is the
derivative of velocity
as a function of
this coordinate.
Derivative of velocity as a
function of that coordinate
multiplied by the separation.
OK?
So what does this
incompressibility condition
mean?
It means that however many
points I had over here,
they end up in a box that has
exactly the same volume, which
means that the density is going
to be the same around here
and around this new point.
So essentially, what we have is
that the rho at the new point,
p prime, q prime, and
time, t, plus dt, is
the same thing as the rho at
the old point, p, q, at time, t.
Again, this is the
incompressibility condition.
Now we do mathematics.
So let's write it again.
So I've said, in other
words, that rho p, q, t
is the same as the
rho at the new point.
What's the momentum
at the new point?
It is p plus.
For each component, it is
p alpha plus p alpha dot.
Let's put it this
way. p plus p dot
dt, q plus q dot
dt, and t plus dt.
That is, if I look at
the new location compared
to the old location, the time
changed, the position changed,
the momentum changed.
They all changed--
in each arguments
changed infinitesimally
by an amount that
is proportional to dt.
And so what I can do is I
can expand this function
to order of dt.
So I have rho at
the original point.
So this is all mathematics.
I just look at
variation with respect
to each one of these arguments.
So I have a sum
over alpha, p alpha
dot d rho by dp
alpha plus q alpha
dot d rho by dq alpha plus
the explicit derivative,
d rho by dt.
This entirety is going
to be multiplied by dt.
And then, in principle,
the expansion
would have higher order terms.
OK?
Now, of course, the
first term vanishes.
It is the same on both times.
So the thing that I
will have to set to 0
is this entity over here.
Now, quite generally, if
you have a function of p,
q, and t, you evaluate
it at the old point
and then evaluate
at the new point.
One can define what is
called a total derivative.
And just like here,
the total derivative
will come from variations
of all of these arguments.
We'll have a partial
derivative with respect
to time and partial
derivatives with respect
to any of the other arguments.
So I wrote this to sort
of make a distinction
between the symbol
that is commonly used,
sometimes d by dt, which is
straight, sometimes Df by Dt.
And this is either
a total derivative
or a streamline derivative.
That is, you are
taking derivatives
as you are moving
along with the flow.
And that is to be distinguished
from these partial derivatives,
which is really sitting
at some point in space
and following how, from one
time instant to another time
instant, let's say
the density changes.
So Df by Dt with
a partial really
means sit at the same point.
Whereas this big Df by Dt
means, go along with the flow
and look at the changes.
Now, what we have established
here is that for the density,
the density has some
special character because
of this Liouville's theorem,
that the streamlined derivative
is 0.
So what we have is
that d rho by dt is 0.
And this d rho by dt
I can also write down
as d rho by dt plus sum
over all 6N directions, d
rho by dp alpha.
But then I substitute for
p alpha dot from here.
p dot is minus dH by dq.
And then I add d
rho by dq alpha.
q alpha dot is dH by dp r.
OK?
So then I can take this
combination with the minus sign
to the other side and
write it as d rho by dt
is something that I will
call the Poisson bracket of H
and rho, where,
quite generally, if I
have two functions
in phase space
that is defending on B and
q, this scalary derivative
the Poisson bracket is
defined as the sum over all 6N
possible variation.
The first one with respect to
q, the second one with respect
to p.
And then the whole thing
with the opposite sign.
dA, dP, dB, dq.
So this is the Poisson bracket.
And again, from
the definition, you
should be able to
see immediately
that Poisson bracket
of A and B is
minus the Poisson
bracket of B and A. OK?
Again, we ask the question
that in general, I
can construct in principle
a rho of p, q, let's say,
for an equilibrium ensemble.
But then I did something,
like I removed a partition
in the middle of the gas,
and the gas is expanding.
And then presumably, this
becomes a function of time.
And since I know exactly how
each one of the particles,
and hence each one
of the micro states
is evolving as a
function of time,
I should be able to tell how
this density in phase space
is changing.
So this perspective is,
again, this perspective
of looking at all of these
bees that are buzzing around
in this 6N-dimensional space,
and asking the question, if I
look at the particular point in
this 6N-dimensional space, what
is the density of bees?
And the answer is
that it is given
by the Poisson bracket
of the Hamiltonian
that governs the evolution
of each micro state
and the density function.
All right.
So what does it mean?
What can we do with this?
Let's play around with it and
look at some consequences.
But before that, does
anybody have any questions?
OK.
All right.
We had something
that I just erased.
That is, if I have a
function of p and q,
let's say it's not
a function of time.
Let's say it's the kinetic
energy for this system where,
at t equals to 0, I
remove the partition,
and the particles are expanding.
And let's say the other
place you have a potential,
so your kinetic energy on
average is going to change.
You want to know what's
happening to that.
So you calculate at
each instant of time
an ensemble average
of the kinetic energy
or any other quantity that
is interesting to you.
And your prescription for
calculating an ensemble average
is that you integrate against
the density the function
that you are
proposing to look at.
Now, in principle,
we said that there
could be situations where
this is dependent on time,
in which case, your average
will also depend on time.
And maybe you want to know how
this time dependence occurs.
How does the kinetic
energy of a gas that
is expanding into some
potential change on average?
OK.
So let's take a look.
This is a function of
time, because, as we said,
these go inside the average.
So really, the only explicit
variable that we have here
is time.
And you can ask,
what is the time
dependence of this quantity?
OK?
So the time dependence is
obtained by doing this,
because essentially, you
would be adding things
at different points in p, q.
And at each point, there
is a time dependence.
And you take the derivative
in time with respect
to the contribution
of that point.
So we get something like this.
Now you say, OK, I know
what d rho by dt is.
So this is my integration
over all of the phase space.
d rho by dt is this Poisson
bracket of H and rho.
And then I have O. OK?
Let's write this explicitly.
This is an integral
over a whole bunch
of coordinates and momenta.
There is, for the
Poisson bracket,
a sum over derivatives.
So I have a sum over
alpha-- dH by dq alpha,
d rho by dp alpha minus dH by
dp alpha, d rho by dq alpha.
And that Poisson
bracket in its entirety
then gets multiplied by this
function of phase space.
OK.
Now, one of the
mathematical manipulations
that we will do a
lot in this class.
And that's why I do this
particular step, although it's
not really necessary to
the logical progression
that I'm following,
is to remind you
how you would do an integration
by parts when you're
faced with something like this.
An integration by
parts is applicable
when you have variables that you
are integrating that are also
appearing as derivatives.
And whenever you are
integrating Poisson brackets,
you will have derivatives
for the Poisson bracket.
And the integration
would allow you
to use integration by parts.
And in particular,
what I would like to do
is to remove the derivative
that acts on the densities.
So I'm going to
essentially rewrite that as
minus an integral
that involves-- again.
I don't want to keep
rewriting that thing.
I want to basically take
the density out and then
have the derivative, which is
this d by dp in the first term
and d by dq in the second
term, act on everything else.
So in the first case, d
by dp alpha will act on O
and dH by dq alpha.
And in the second case, d
by dq alpha will act on O
and dH by dp alpha.
Again, there is a sum over
alpha that is implicit.
OK?
Again, there is a minus sign.
So every time you do this
procedure, there is this.
But every time, you also have
to worry about surface terms.
So on the surface,
you would potentially
have to evaluate things that
involve rho, O, and these d
by d derivatives.
But let's say we are
integrating over momentum
from minus infinity to infinity.
Then the density evaluated at
infinity momenta would be 0.
So practicality, in all
cases that I can think of,
you don't have to worry
about the boundary terms.
So then when you look
at these kinds of terms,
this d by dp alpha
can either act on O.
So I will get dO by dp
alpha, dH by dq alpha.
Or it can act on dH by d alpha.
So I will get plus O d2
H, dp alpha dq alpha.
And similarly, in
this term, either I
will have dO by dq alpha, dH by
dp alpha, or O d2 H, dq alpha
dp alpha.
Once more, the second
derivative terms
of the Hamiltonian, the
order is not important.
And what is left
here is this set
of objects, which is none
other than the Poisson bracket.
So I can rewrite the whole thing
as d by dt of the expectation
value of this quantity,
which potentially
is a function of time
because of the time
dependence of my density
is the same thing
as minus an integration over
the entire phase space of rho
against this entity,
which is none
other than the Poisson
bracket of H with O.
And this integration over
density of this entire space
is just our definition
of the expectation value.
So we get that the time
derivative of any quantity
is related to the average
of its Poisson bracket
with the Hamiltonian, which
is the quantity that is really
governing time dependences.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could
you explain again
why the time derivative
when N is the integral,
it's rho as a
partial derivative?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So suppose I'm doing a
two-dimensional integral
over p and q.
So I have some contribution
from each point in this p and q.
And so my integral
is an integral dpdq,
something evaluated
at each point in p,
q that could potentially
depend on time.
Imagine that I discretize this.
So I really-- if you
are more comfortable,
you can think of this
as a limit of a sum.
So this is my integral.
If I'm interested in the time
dependence of this quantity--
and I really depends
only on time,
because I integrated
over p and q.
So if I'm interested
in something
that is a sum of
various terms, each term
is a function of time.
Where do I put the
time dependence?
For each term in this sum, I
look at how it depends on time.
I don't care on its points
to the left and to the right.
OK?
Because the big D by Dt involves
moving with the streamline.
I'm not doing any moving
with the streamline.
I'm looking at each point in
this two-dimensional space.
Each point gives a
contribution at that point
that is time-dependent.
And I take the derivative with
respect to time at that point.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you say
that you have function O
as just some
function of p and q,
and its time derivative
would be Poisson bracket?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And does the
average of the time derivative
would be the average
of Poisson bracket,
and you don't have to
go through all the--
PROFESSOR: No.
But you can see the
sign doesn't work.
AUDIENCE: How come?
PROFESSOR: [LAUGHS]
Because of all
of these manipulations,
et cetera.
So the statement that you
made is manifestly incorrect.
You can't say that the time
dependence of this thing
is the-- whatever you
were saying. [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's see what you are saying.
AUDIENCE: So
Poisson bracket only
counts for in place
for averages, right?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what do we have here?
We have that dp by dt is the
Poisson bracket of H and rho.
OK?
And we have that O is an
integral of rho O. Now,
from where do you conclude
from this set of results
that d O by dt is the
average of a Poisson bracket
that involves O
and H, irrespective
of what we do with the sign?
AUDIENCE: Or if you look not
at the average failure of O
but at the value of O
and point, and take-- I
guess it would be
streamline derivative of it.
So that's assuming that you're
just like assigning value of O
to each point, and making
power changes with time
as this point moves
across the phase space.
PROFESSOR: OK.
But you still have to do some
bit of derivatives, et cetera,
because--
AUDIENCE: But if you know
that the volume of the
in phase space is
conserved, then we basically
don't care much
that the function
O is any much different
from probability density.
PROFESSOR: OK.
If I understand correctly,
this is what you are saying.
Is that for each
representative point,
I have an O alpha, which
is a function of time.
And then you want to say
that the average of O
is the same thing as the sum
over alpha of O alpha of t's
divided by N,
something like this.
AUDIENCE: Eh.
Uh, I want to first calculate
what does time derivative of O?
O remains in a function
of time and q and p.
So I can calculate--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So this O alpha is a function of
AUDIENCE: So if I said--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK.
Fine.
AUDIENCE: O is a function
of q and p and t,
and I take a streamline
derivative of it.
So filter it with respect to t.
And then I average that
thing over phase space.
And then I should get
the same version--
PROFESSOR: You should.
AUDIENCE: --perfectly.
But--
PROFESSOR: Very quickly,
I don't think so.
Because you are already
explaining things a bit
longer than I think I went
through my derivation.
But that's fine. [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Is there any special--
PROFESSOR: But I
agree in spirit, yes.
That each one of these will
go along its streamline,
and you can calculate the
change for each one of them.
And then you have to do an
average of this variety.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] when
you talk about time derivative
of probability density, it's
Poisson bracket of H and rho.
But when you talk about
time derivative of average,
you have to add the minus sign.
PROFESSOR: And if you
do this correctly here,
you should get the same result.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, along
that line, though,
are you using the fact
that phase space volume is
incompressible to then
argue that the total time
derivative of the
ensemble average
is the same as the ensemble
average of the total time
derivative of O, or not?
PROFESSOR: Could
you repeat that?
Mathematically,
you want me to show
that the time derivative
of what quantity?
AUDIENCE: Of the average of O.
PROFESSOR: Of the
average of O. Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it in any
way related to the average
of dO over dt?
PROFESSOR: No, it's not.
Because O-- I mean, so
what do you mean by that?
You have to be careful, because
the way that I'm defining this
here, O is a
function of p and q.
And what you want to do
is to write something
that is a sum over all
representative points, divided
by the total number, some
kind of an average like this.
And then I can define
a time derivative here.
Is that what you are--
AUDIENCE: Well, I
mean, I was thinking
that even if you start out with
your observable being defined
for every point in phase
space, then if you were to,
before doing any
ensemble averaging,
if you were to take the total
time derivative of that,
then you would be accounted for
p dot and q dot as well, right?
And then if you were
to take the ensemble
average of that
quantity, could you
arrive at the same
result for that?
PROFESSOR: I'm pretty sure that
if you do things consistently,
yes.
That is, what we have
done is essentially
we started with a collection
of trajectories in phase space
and recast the result in
terms of density and variables
that are defined only as
positions in phase space.
The two descriptions
completely are equivalent.
And as long as one
doesn't make a mistake,
one can get one or the other.
This is actually a kind
of a well-known thing
in hydrodynamics, because
typically, you write down,
in hydrodynamics, equations
for density and velocity
at each point in phase space.
But there is an
alternative description
which we can say that there's
essentially particles that are
flowing.
And particle that was
here at this location
is now somewhere else
at some later time.
And people have tried hard.
And there is a
consistent definition
of hydrodynamics that follows
the second perspective.
But I haven't seen it
as being practical.
So I'm sure that everything
that you guys say is correct.
But from the experience of
what I know in hydrodynamics,
I think this is the more
practical description
that people have been using.
OK?
So where were we?
OK.
So back to our buzzing bees.
We now have a way
of looking at how
densities and various quantities
that you can calculate,
like ensemble averages, are
changing as a function of time.
But the question
that I had before
is, what about equilibrium?
Because the thermodynamic
definition of equilibrium,
and my whole ensemble idea,
was that essentially, I
have all of these
boxes and pressure,
volume, everything
that I can think of,
as long as I'm not
doing something that's
like opening the box, is
perfectly independent of time.
So how can I ensure that
various things that I calculate
are independent of time?
Clearly, I can do that by having
this density not really depend
on time.
OK?
Now, of course, each
representative point
is moving around.
Each micro state
Each bee is moving around.
But I want the density that is
characteristic of equilibrium
be something that does
not change in time.
It's 0.
And so if I posit that this
particular function of p and q
is something that is not
changing as a function of time,
I have to require that
the Poisson bracket
of that function of p and
q with the Hamiltonian,
which is another function
of p and q, is 0.
OK?
So in principle,
I have to go back
to this equation over here,
which is a partial differential
equation in 6N-dimensional
space and solve with equal to 0.
Of course, rather than doing
that, we will guess the answer.
And the guess is clear from
here, because all I need to do
is to make rho equilibrium
depend on coordinates in phase
space through some functional
dependence on Hamiltonian,
which depends on the
coordinates in phase space.
OK?
Why does this work?
Because then when I take the
Poisson bracket of, let's
say, this function of H with
H, what do I have to do?
I have to do a sum over
alpha d rho with respect
to, let's say-- actually,
let's write it in this way.
I will have the dH by
dp alpha from here.
I have to multiply
by d rho by dq alpha.
But rho is a function
of only H. So I
have to take a derivative of rho
with respect to its argument H.
And I'll call that rho prime.
And then the derivative
of the argument,
which is H, with
respect to q alpha.
That would be the first term.
The next term would be, with
the minus sign, from the H here,
dH by dq alpha, the derivative
of rho with respect to p alpha.
But rho only depends on H, so I
will get the derivative of rho
with respect to
its one argument.
The derivative of that argument
with respect to p alpha.
OK?
So you can see that up to
the order of the terms that
are multiplying here, this is 0.
OK?
So any function I choose of H,
in principle, satisfies this.
And this is what we
will use consistently
all the time in
statistical mechanics,
in depending on the
ensemble that we have.
Like you probably
know that when we
are in the micro
canonical ensemble,
we look at-- in the
micro canonical ensemble,
we'd say what the energy is.
And then we say
that the density is
a delta function--
essentially zero.
Except places, it's
the surface that
corresponds to having
the right energy.
So you sort of
construct in phase space
the surface that has
the right energy.
So it's a function
of these four.
So this is the micro canonical.
When you are in the
canonical, I use
a rho this is proportional
to e to the minus beta H
and other functional features.
So it's, again, the same idea.
OK?
That's almost but
not entirely true,
because sometimes there are
also other conserved quantities.
Let's say that, for example, we
have a collection of particles
in space in a cavity that
has the shape of a sphere.
Because of the symmetry
of the problem,
angular momentum is going
to be a conserved quantity.
Angular momentum
you can also write
as some complicated
function of p and q.
For example, p cross q summed
over all of the particles.
But it could be some
other conserved quantity.
So what does this
conservation law mean?
It means that if you
evaluate L for some time,
it is going to be the
same L for the coordinates
and momenta at some other time.
Or in other words,
dL by dt, which
you obtained by summing
over all coordinates dL
by dp alpha, p alpha dot, plus
dL by dq alpha q alpha dot.
Essentially, taking
time derivatives
of all of the arguments.
And I did not put any
explicit time dependence here.
And this is again sum
over alpha dL by dp alpha.
p alpha dot is minus
dH by dq alpha.
And dL by dq alpha, q alpha
dot is dH by dp alpha.
So you are seeing that
this is the same thing
as the Poisson
bracket of L and H.
So essentially, conserved
quantities which
are essentially functions
of coordinates and momenta
that you calculate that don't
change as a function of time
are also quantities
that have zero Poisson
brackets with the Hamiltonian.
So if I have a
conserved quantity,
then I have a more
general solution.
To my d rho by dt
equals to 0 requirement.
I could make a rho
equilibrium which
is a function of H of p and q,
as well as, say, L of p and q.
And when you go through the
Poisson bracket process,
you will either be
taking derivatives
with respect to the
first argument here.
So you would get rho prime with
respect to the first argument.
And then you would get the
Poisson bracket of H and H.
Or you would be getting
derivatives with respect
to the second argument.
And then you would be getting
the Poisson bracket of L and H.
And both of them are 0.
By definition, L is
a conserved quantity.
So any solution that's a
function of Hamiltonian,
the energy of the
system is conserved
as a function of
time, as well as
any other conserved quantities,
such as angular momentum,
et cetera, is certainly
a valid thing.
So indeed, when I drew here, in
the micro canonical ensemble,
a surface that corresponds
to a constant energy,
well, if I am in a
spherical cavity,
only part of that
surface that corresponds
to the right angular momentum
is going to be accessible.
So essentially, what I know
is that if I have conserved
quantities, my trajectories
will explore the subspace
that is consistent with
those conservation laws.
And this statement here is that
ultimately, those spaces that
correspond to the
appropriate conservation law
are equally populated.
Rho is constant around.
So in some sense, we started
with the definition of rho
by putting these points
around and calculating
probability that way, which
was my objective definition
of probability.
And through this
Liouville theorem,
we have arrived
at something that
is more consistent with
the subjective assignment
of probability.
That is, the only
thing that I know,
forgetting about
the dynamics, is
that there are some
conserved quantities,
such as H, angular
momentum, et cetera.
And I say that any point in
phase space that does not
violate those constants in this,
say, micro canonical ensemble
would be equally populated.
There was a question somewhere.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I almost feel like
the statement that the rho has
to not change in time is too
strong, because if you go over
to the equation that
says the rate of change
is observable is equal
to the integral that
was with a Poisson
bracket of rho and H, then
it means that for
any observable,
it's constant in time, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So rho of q means
any observable we can think of,
its function of p
and q is constant?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Yep.
Because-- and that's
the best thing that we
can think of in terms
of-- because if there
is some observable that
is time-dependent--
let's say 99 observables
are time-independent,
but one is time-dependent,
and you can measure that,
would you say your
system is in equilibrium?
Probably not.
OK?
AUDIENCE: It seemed
like the same method
that you did to show that
the density is a function of
[INAUDIBLE], or
[INAUDIBLE] that it's
the function of any observable
that's a function of q.
Right?
PROFESSOR: Observables?
No.
I mean, here, if
this answer is 0,
it states something about
this quantity averaged.
So if this quantity does not
change as a function of time,
it is not a statement
that H and 0 is 0.
A statement that H and O is 0
is different from its ensemble
average being 0.
What you can show-- and I think
I have a problem set for that--
is that if this statement
is correct for every O
that the average
is 0, then your rho
has to satisfy
this theorem equals
to-- Poisson bracket of
rho and H is equal to 0.
OK.
So now the big question
is the following.
We arrived that the way of
thinking about equilibrium
in a system of
particles and things
that are this many-to-one
mapping, et cetera, in terms
of the densities-- we arrived
that the definition of what
the density is going
to be in equilibrium.
But the thermodynamic statement
is much, much more severe.
The statement, again,
is that if I have a box
and I open the door
of the box, the gas
expands to fill the empty space
or the other part of the box.
And it will do so all the time.
Yet the equations of motion
that we have over here
are time reversal invariant.
And we did not manage
to remove that.
We can show that this
Liouville equation, et cetera,
is also time reversal invariant.
So for every case,
if you succeed
to show that there is a density
that is in half of the box
and it expands to
fill the entire box,
there will be a density that
presumably goes the other way.
Because that will be also a
solution of this equation.
So when we sort of go back
from the statement of what
is the equilibrium
solution and ask,
do I know that I will eventually
reach this equilibrium
solution as a function of
time, we have not shown that.
And we will attempt
to do so next time.